[Musique]
oui bienvenue par agatha christie mise à
mal depuis sept semaines je veux
rebondir sur les actualités donc on en
parlait beaucoup dans les dernières
semaines c'était vraiment les langues
autochtones mais particulièrement parce
que le 31 mars est la journée nationale
des langues autochtones au canada et je
pense qu'avec la discussion qu'on a eue
dans les dernières semaines autour des
enjeux que ça miaule dû faire face pour
le festival par exemple la chanson de
granby par rapport au fait que justement
les langues autochtones sont pas du tout
encore reconnu officiellement est bien
je pense que c'est un sujet qui est
d'actualité surtout que 2022 c'est
l'année de départ pour la décennie des
langues autochtones selon l'unesco donc
devoir être porté de l'avant et ce qui
me trouble et au début c'était vraiment
le côté réfractaires de des langues
avoir envers les langues autochtones
mais par exemple le support qui est venu
par la suite mais est venu me faire
rêver le dire parce que je les regardais
un peu la déclaration des ministres
année dernière par rapport au 31 mars
2021 et on dire on veut reconnaître on
on veut mettre de l'avant mais ce que je
voyais c'est quand même une
reconnaissance très symbolique je pense
qu'on peut essayer tête d'aller de
l'avant je rêve le rêve mais d'aller
reconnaître c'est l'angle officiellement
de faire de 2020 d'un processus de
protection des langues autochtones sur
leur territoire je m'attends pas à ce
que lee nous aimons soient protégés de
la même manière sur la côte ouest qui
elle peut l'être sur mon territoire mais
par exemple d'aider chaque communauté
justement là pour mettre de l'avant des
programmes à pouvoir financer de la même
manière que le français est financé pour
la protéger
sur les territoires donc je pense
beaucoup au travail de fou que
l'institut tshakapesh par en fait depuis
des décennies pour aider à faire en
sorte qu'on venait du matériel
didactique des sites web des
applications des enseignants qui parle
d'une hormone est que cette transmission
le ce rende jusqu'à des gens comme moi
par exemple qui par l'éducation à cause
des pensionnés à cause de toutes les
tourments intergénérationnel liés aux
langues autochtones et bien je n'ai pas
appris quand j'étais jeune on favorise
et autant de france on ne tente pas bien
français donc je me fais de dire que je
tombe à bonn en français mais
aujourd'hui particulièrement quand j'ai
eu la vingtaine qui je me suis rendu
compte que j'étais une adulte puis que
je serai à parler ma langue alors que
j'ai été élevé dans une communauté qui
la parlent est complètement bien ça m'a
donné un coup au carré de plus en plus à
mesure que je vieillis et bien je me
rends compte que des générations qui
elles sont élevées dans la langue il
nous la connaissent peut-être pas autant
que nos parents que nos grands-parents
et là je vois comment justement le
manque de financement le manque d'appui
des langues autochtones
un impact sur les jeunes dans nos
communautés donc aller les favorisant en
lançant des concours en disant on va
favoriser les langues autochtones et le
français par exemple à la radio je vois
des jeunes qui vont vouloir ré apprendre
leur langue un peu le processus qui est
la mienne en fait pour que son album en
anishnabe mohand soit une réalité
aujourd'hui avec par rapport à ses
débuts c'est fantastique c'est des
choses qui me font rêver et de penser
que justement il ya une compréhension
des enjeux le particulier quand je parle
avec des francophones qui eux
comprennent aussi la distinction d'avoir
des langues autochtones et des langues
francophone protéger parce que le
français c'est pas juste le français
c'est le chiac c'est le ba ba yo c'est
le caillou c'est toutes les distinctions
linguistique qui existe dans le français
qui sont belles et qui sont à protéger
même le français radio-canadien condom
on rigole souvent quand on en parle au
passé est-ce que saleh à mener
aujourd'hui toutes ces enjeux-là de
langue francophone peuvent juste être
transposée justement sur les langues
autochtones par rapport au besoin d'agir
maintenant dans la protection des lans
donc 31 mars je vous invite sérieusement
si vous êtes un secteur où je peux vous
savez déjà ce que vous avez à faire vous
avez même pas besoin d'avoir fait rire
c'est une réalité depuis la naissance
mais si vous êtes des alliés que vous
voulez justement amener un support va
demander de plus en plus de femmes à vos
élus de regarder en
en face justement là la réalité qui est
demandé par les communautés autochtones
ses dires de protéger les langues
autochtones au canada maintenant ne pas
attendre dans dix ans pour dire ok on a
passé une décennie pour célébrer en
bonus on va les soutenir on va les
officialiser sait maintenant qu'il doit
y avoir de l'action maintenant qu'une
protection des langues
voici moi ce que je fais pour le 31 ça
va être vraiment des activités avec les
enfants par exemple autour de la langue
parce que c'est déjà des choses qu'il me
demande est grande justement à des
organismes qui devrait pas être
uniquement financés à titre d'organisme
autochtone mais aussi financer comme des
lieux d'enseignement des langues bien
j'adore utiliser ces outils là pour leur
transmettre de plus en plus dingues et
moi au passage en apprendre beaucoup
plus avec eux alors 31 célébrer avec
nous supporter et nous n'en dit
justement que ces langues officielles
officialisé puis officiel et je pense
que des fois ça peut être le petit coup
de pouce quand ça vient du milieu à
l'automne chamakh qui va réveiller
ce qu'on appelle les politiques à mettre
en action justement quelque chose qui va
être réel et qui va donner un impact sur
nos langues la protection de nos plans
alors je vous souhaite une belle semaine
n'hésitez pas à partager une vidéo il
n'était pas non plus à nous envoyer des
questions merci énormément d'être là
chaque semaine